das thema war ihm die rechtlich
umgesetzt heißt mir nicht den finger
das war für mich der martin m ist das
finde ich so fies von dir dass du das
nie so fies das buch war für das ist
auch überhaupt das natürlich war ein
absolut wichtiges buch ich glaube
interessengebiet ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher später auch keine rolle weil das
muss man gar nicht auf dem radar haben
bist du nur eine liebesgeschichte in
einem konzentration ist leise und er war
kz leiter und das aller schrecklichste
an diesem buch war nicht
liebesgeschichte sondern war dass er
quasi wie eine art zynische karikatur
war und gleichzeitig diese
liebesgeschichte so ernsthaft
dargestellt wurde
ich bin ja eigentlich immer sehr
wohlwollend mit literatur fällt mir auf
hier ist also also im gegensatz zu
diesen worum es für meine begriffe geht
nämlich um diesen eklatanten kontrast
zwischen einer liebesgeschichte in der
hölle und zweitens geht es darum dass
man hier plötzlich nicht mehr so genau
operieren kann mit gut und böse es ging
mir darum dass es passagen gab in denen
sondern seine 13
du kannst nicht eine ein ernsthaftes
anliegen in eine und das hat es übrigens
der variant zürich bei der lesung ich
weiß ich hab die moduliert ja und ich
war gast und er hat es selber auch
gesagt er hat karikaturhaft moment rein
geschrieben in diesem roman manchmal hat
man doch so bücher die einen einfach
wirklich verändern und ich kann ohne zu
übertreiben sagen dass es bei diesem
buch von mathias so war für ein
entsprechendes buch bei dir
das ist ein guter ja aber schön für dich